[Music]
and we're gonna be homeless
we're getting kicked out why should we
do it I'm gonna have to sell you for
drugs
oh hey today's the last day in the old
office we are getting kicked out we
cleaned it all up it looks nice and
beautiful it's - aunt Goei Nia can we
move room so if you're not up just to
date with the story we were shooting a
video the door is knocking bang bang
bang were just finished landlord comes
down call us as [ __ ] say he owns the
building and then we need to be shut the
[ __ ] up now a lot of news stories
covered this story OPD plan getting
kicked out because he's too loved what a
[ __ ] idiot what does he just buy a
hose I'll buy your your house first of
all there's no [ __ ] houses in
Brighton all right so you can see we
just start there
second of all we got kicked out without
any notice of a noise complaint which is
pretty crazy if you think about it I
know we're being loud but not how do we
know if we're being too loud if no-one
tells us we're being too loud think
about that if a tree falls you know
whatever naturally if someone said hey
you're being too loud we would have been
like sorry we won't shoot in that room
anymore the real story is that the guy
thought we were having sex I'll show a
clip of the video that we were shooting
right before he came down
don't get me did we have sex no we can't
say for sure but it seems clearly this
guy is a homophobe and he wants us out
because he thinks were a gay couple
having sex I can't think of a reason
otherwise where you just throw someone
out without a noise complaint I don't
even know if it's legal to do that it I
don't I don't think so the landlord has
been acting weird as [ __ ] about the
whole situation afterward as well
the landlord thought I wasn't here
because he saw me leave but Michael was
still here and he filmed it let's show
that footage
hello
hello-o
are you serious you come in my apartment
oh yeah that's but when I'm not here and
whenever the time you could come in
whenever you want to press the bell to
watch that's one doesn't matter you
can't come in one day so seeing it this
is the last day and the landlord is a
massive homophobe what else is there to
do it's time for me to have a gay party
[Music]
would you like to join me for a dance on
the dance floor
[Music]
that's what I saw him what the [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] put this in the video
[Music]